okay ross let's go let's go well this
you guys audience
this really happened drew and i on a
commercial break a couple weeks ago
we're talking about noodle recipes and i
said oh i've got my noodles she's got
hers
today we're gonna go noodle and noodle
all right noodle on it mine is up first
but let me get while
i talk let me get a little um olive oil
in this pan all right this recipe is so
simple i have lost like 50 pounds drew
cooking
uh for myself but i need things to taste
like
real things if i'm making pasta i want
to taste like pasta right yeah
i i lost 30 pounds last year you did
was it all about cooking yourself and
using good ingredients it was basically
what we're doing here which is that i
would give up on diets because that
chicken and broccoli thing just gets old
miserable totally
and you don't end up sticking to it you
always rebel at least i did
so i have found a way to make foods that
are delicious but with alternative
ingredients
absolutely that's exactly what we're
doing here i love a really good pasta
with
fresh veg i just put some um uh that
smells
so good i'm freaking out i just put a
little bit of garlic in here with some
tomatoes
um i have some artichokes hearts here
but you really can use whatever you have
in the fridge so if like my
broccoli is about to go bad i throw that
in some zucchini whatever you want
i'm putting just artichoke hearts in
here a little salt i did that with some
pepper i like a little heat
a little bit yeah because i'm old and my
palate's dull okay
okay all right thank you i have some
peeled
cooked shrimp here it's already cooked
you could use chicken you could use
sausage you could use ham whatever you
wanted so sort of like a primavera
with any vegetables that you have on
hand
mixed with a little protein so that it
feels really
satisfying yeah you can you put a ton of
vegetables in here and you're eating
like a whole plate of something but it's
all good for you
the veggies so these are my noodles you
guys they're called i found these
uh in the grocery store they're called
miracle noodles yup all right they're
like
fiber or something they're zero calories
zero carbs it's like the plants it's
water i don't know
but it comes anything like this every
grocery store it's in there like in the
refrigerated area let me just put the
noodles in here i rinse them
put them in here and you just kind of
want all you do is heat them up it's
like you don't have to cook the noodles
because they're
already like all limp isn't that crazy
and then i take a little how does the
sauce adhere to them well
you have to like take it off the heat
for a second and then it soaks it up you
know good pasta soaks up all the sauce
you can add a little water to it a
little more oil if it needs
i'm putting a little fresh basil in here
and you see how simple that is
that's gorgeous and then you can serve
it which i'll just put do right here
and then put a little parmesan on top
and i made you one already over there if
you want to try it oh
you didn't have to invite me ross i'm
right there ready to try your noodles
[Applause]
i am i'm waiting the whole segment for
this oh i've been waiting my whole life
for this i know right
me too roz okay i'ma put a little
parmesan on mine now be honest if you
like this noodle
don't tell me you like it if you don't i
promise okay although you made like a
spam pie taste amazing so i have a lot
of faith thank you
it's delicious
my concern with these noodles is that
they wouldn't have flavor and these are
incredibly flavorful because they're
still
chewy it doesn't taste like even though
it's a root of something it's amazing
it tastes like pasta right mm-hmm
these are so savory
and spicy and zesty and delicious
and really most importantly incredibly
flavorful
good i'm glad you like it there's a
little salt there if you need it too no
i know you have a noodle that you're
going to
share for me thank you mm-hmm
[Music]
that kind of is like the ultimate
compliment when you don't have to season
it no salt needed
yeah that's to drop the mic thank you to
drop the salt shaker that is
so good
[Music]